la creación de un g20 por la paz en
Ucrania es una iniciativa del presidente
de Brasil en un viaje a abu dhabi para
visitar al jeque Mohamed vincied Lula se
presentó como mediador en el conflicto
ayer hablé con el jeque sobre la guerra
hablé con la guerra y creo que estamos
encontrando un conjunto de personas que
prefieren hablar de paz que de guerra
creo que va a funcionar
antes de visitar emiratos árabes Unidos
Lula estuvo en China donde Ucrania
también figuraba en la agenda el
presidente brasileño ha dicho que Moscú
y kiev tienen la misma responsabilidad
en la guerra y con ello no ha dudado en
criticar a Estados Unidos y a la Unión
Europea por su apoyo militar a Ucrania
Estados Unidos Tiene que dejar de
fomentar la guerra y empezar a hablar de
paz la Unión Europea tiene que empezar a
hablar de paz para que podamos convencer
a putinski de que la paz interesa a todo
el mundo
a través de su portavoz la Unión Europea
respondió a Lula
no es verdad que la Unión Europea y
Estados Unidos alargan el conflicto
Ucrania es víctima de una agresión que
viola la carta de Naciones Unidas y
estamos ayudando a Ucrania a defenderse
porque si no afrontaría su destrucción
Lula se dio como objetivo formar un
grupo de países que hasta ahora se han
mantenido neutrales en el conflicto para
mediar en La Paz entre Rusia y Ucrania
sin embargo Brasil tiene una relación
privilegiada con Rusia como país miembro
del bricks una asociación que También
incluye a China India y Sudáfrica lo que
ha detenido la condena brasileña de la
invasión rusa Lula incluso sugirió que
Ucrania debería renunciar a la Península
de crimea anexionada ilegalmente por
Rusia en 2014